stop faking it hit it when people fake
it this is the Ghostbuster headquarter
Evan looks like Nicholas Cage just keep
going
good morning good morning it's day three
three five five and now day three four
five the whole time three three in New
York Times the whole time being lied to
we're going to breakfast let's go
laughs
so we finished the the coffee and
breakfast place it's okay it was not as
good as what I remember but the kids
enjoyed it
right they didn't even finish the they
didn't even finish their sandwich
I have to eat hers and and I wasn't
planning to eat but I just ate anyways I
got very full right now so I need to
walk it up and then off to our next stop
I don't know what uh where and what
[Music]
this is the Ghostbuster headquarter
we're just gonna sightseeing
this is where they filmed it
[Music]
all right we're gonna head over to Times
Square but before we go to Times Square
we need to take the subway
hey man we're at Times Square where are
we going Midtown Comics first stop
what's in Midtown Comics
stranger things
I hate it
[Music]
we stopped by the comp DC comic store no
one got anything they just they just
kind of walk around and then that's it
alright off to the next stop I don't
know where just keep going
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
all right this is the place this is
where we need to go
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
looks like Nicholas Cage
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
Island
let's go
[Music]
thank you
do you like the waxing Museum what's the
rating what you're giving the rating for
and I still remember I got last and a 70
Carnival right
Sanders sadness wax museum was fun it
was good kids enjoyed it yeah we well we
started the morning together and then we
split up in the afternoon yeah Aiden
loves Broadway musicals so I took him to
go watch Hamilton but the uh our niece
and nephew didn't want to see a musical
they went through the wax museum so we
split up I Miss Nina tremendously I was
having an emotional breakdown on him did
you really
no you're fake okay stop faking I hate
it when people fake it
okay don't be fake just be real okay
just say you had a good time that's it
so we watched the shows
Nina came back early relax I came back I
came back I finished like two hours
before then says okay I'm not gonna sit
at Times Square wait two hours so I just
you know I just go home first I just go
back to the hotel and that's like and I
told Jeffrey you know what I told
Jeffrey's like I'm gonna go back let's
go back uh okay do you know how to get
bags of course I know how to get back
and it's like I don't trust you I was
like what I came to New York more did
not go Evan of course I didn't have to
get back have you I don't know about
that yeah I've been doing more than
recently since we've been together I
guess yeah I went I've went I've been to
New York a lot okay anyways yeah anyway
so then we had dinner and then we're
here and now we're wrapping up tomorrow
is our last exciting day we're doing the
strangest things experience we're gonna
be doing some Brooklyn fun before
driving home
so if you want to see what happens and
all that awesomeness check the video
right there next to us you'll love it
continue to believe and we'll see you
there